and with cyto Sensi you can't be good
enough there would be 50 150 people on
the map and he'd be shouting at someone
right the back and he go get him and and
he pull him out and you go and you say
Sensei why do you pick on that person so
far back the picture's wrong what do you
mean he said they come to me I don't go
looking for
them you see you know if you if you sort
of like see
this that person I go oh he's got it
wrong I'm not picking on you or you the
picture is wrong so I loved him and his
analogies because they were so simple he
said if the you know yes these people
who do a Thousand Cuts he said means
that I've got to do a thousand and one
to correct
them because he said they've already
instilled this in their body
right so what you don't want to do is
you don't want to come high that seems
to be quite a normal thing the level
it's on is the level you do it
at the level it's on is the level you do
it at the level it's
on is the level you do it
at I don't want you do the rim and egy
yet I'm just uh trying to show you some
points
here the engaging is not there it's
controlled by this hip and this hip so
I'm going to this hand will turn as this
hip turns and I've got to get it I can't
go a bit there a bit there it's got to
be like a a gear
wheel right it's got to be like a gear
wheel Che
Naggy go gosh so the things you can't
see I'm trying to tell you
so this is in line with this so This
draws it might not be drawing much I'm
not going to have a lot but but look
just a little draw cuz I need him just
like sensey John said you need UK to be
in a
[Music]
position see it's getting worse the
timing so it your over the years over
the years like you said it's it's
working on things so that you start to
understand at every any level that oh I
need to work on
them so you've got a rem and naggie if
you want it I'd like you to do perhaps a
sheer naggie
I'd like you to do a cat of G
Inside Outside they both have the draw
even this one doesn't leave him there it
has the draw from the beginning the very
very
beginning the very beginning it has the
draw has the draw at the very
beginning all right so you got them to
and the other one is you have the drawer
and you go
thanks because that draw gives you the
energy to shoot in okay so you got three
techniques we're going to do that first
and then we're going to give it a bit
make it a bit more challenging